so in many applications
uh relations between an n vector and an
m vector are
either are approximated sometimes the
approximation is very good
as linear or affine right so um
sometimes the approximation is really
good and holds over
like you know holds out at the you know
fifth and sixth decimal place or
something
an example of that would be
electromagnetics or for example
acoustics there are many cases where
it's just
like that function is basically linear
now sometimes it is the approximation
is just it's pretty good over smaller
ranges so for example
aircraft dynamics right if i take an
airplane
and i ask what are the forces and
torques
that are put on the airplane you know
as a function of its speed and sort of
the angle of it
the the angle of attack and the control
surface deflections
that's approximately uh
fine um for you know reasonable ranges
uh certainly for most of the ranges
that you would be comfortable flying an
airplane in um
but it doesn't hold when the when you
you know the airplane is like falling
out of the sky or upside down or
something like that
okay now in other cases uh still the
approximation
is quite approximate like it's plus
minus 50
or worse um but it's still super useful
so uh that's for example in econometric
uh models right so um i mean just
to put something on this you know my
colleagues in electrical engineering
when they're doing e
m you know their models they can predict
things to
three significant figures quite easily
right so
that's good uh my friends who work at
hedge funds uh they
they basically put it this way they say
uh
we're we're happy if we get the sign
right okay
so but nevertheless it's still useful
okay so our first example is from
economics
so here we have n goods or services uh
i'll just imagine them to be n
goods um and we have the prices for
those goods the market prices
are given by an invector p uh here
um so p3 is the pr is the current price
of item or good three and we have demand
and that's given as an n vector
d so d4 is the demand the number of
units
of good four okay and then what you do
is you you what we're going to do is
we're going to change we're going to
imagine changing the prices
uh and so uh what we do is we take the
the new price uh that's p i new that's
the new price for
for item or good i minus pi so if that's
positive it's a price increase if it's
negative it's a decrease
and we divide by pi or the prices i
should say are all positive
okay and that's that that has a
beautiful interpretation as the
fractional
change in prices and we're going to call
that delta
price sub i right so if that
is equal to plus 0.1 that means
basically you just
increase the price of that item by 10
percent
right if it's minus 0.05 that means
you just decrease the price on that item
by five percent
okay so highly interpretable so that's
what the the delta vector gives you
delta price vector it tells you the
fractional changes in the prices for
those goods
okay now we do the same with demand
right we have the fractional change in
demand
right so if uh we subtract
from the new demand we subtract the
the current demand or something like
that we divide by the current demand
and uh demand also by the way is
positive and so uh this is the
fractional change in the demands
right so that that's how that uh that's
the idea so for example
if delta dem sub 2
is minus 0.1 that says
that the change in demand
for good or item 2 went down
10 so highly interpretable okay now
clearly there's some relation between
the prices and the demands we all know
that if
you have a single thing and you increase
the price the demand
goes down okay and what relates them is
called
elasticity uh the elasticity in fact
that's called the price demand
elasticity
and in for multiple goods there's a very
common model
and it looks like this it says that the
vector
of demands is a matrix e
uh called the elasticity matrix uh
times the change the relative changes in
prices uh delta price
okay now that's super interesting
a is an e is an n by n matrix
it's called the elasticity matrix and
it's
highly interpretable and it's very
important to understand like what it
means
so for example e11 is minus 0.3
what does that mean well e11
tells you uh how much does the price
of the first entry tells you sorry
how much does the demand that's the
first the first one
so we say one how much does the demand
for
item one change
uh per fractional change in the price of
item one
and this says minus point three and so
here here's a specific
this is a very specific conclusion this
says
if you increase if you increase the
price
by 10 by let's let's make it less like
let's increase it by one percent right
if we increase the price for item one or
good one
by ten percent our model the price
demand
elasticity model predicts that the
demand will go down
by point three percent okay so that
that's what it says
oh you can ask another question does
your profit go up or down
and that depends on how much it costs
you to manufacture and all that sort of
stuff so we're
here we're just predicting how the
demand is going to change
of course people are interested in how
the demand is going to change for two
reasons number one for supply chain
you want to make sure you can you can
actually have that amount of
that good on hand and the other thing is
you want to find out
what happens to your profit does it go
up or down okay so all right
um e12 equals plus 0.1
super interesting let's see what it says
that says that under the price demand
elasticity model
if you increase the price of
uh good two by let's say one percent
this says you can you can expect
the demand for good number one to go
up by point one percent so
increasing the price of the second good
increases the demand of the first good
now that comes up all the time and what
people call but in
economics these are referred to as
substitutes right
that you know when that somehow if
people say oh that's more expensive i'm
not i'm i'm buying less of it right so
that would be
e 2 2 you know is minus
you know 0.2 or something right so if
you increase the price
it says that the demand for good two the
demand for good two goes down but demand
for a good one goes up
because they're somehow they're it's you
know it's you know they're
they're substitutes right so that's
that's that's the idea
um here's one e23 was minus 0.05
that tells you that if the if you
increase the price of good five it says
that the demand for good two goes down
and sorry if you sorry if you increase
the the price for good three
then the demand for good two
goes down um and it's quite specific
about how much it goes down it's it's
not much right uh but
it's so what that that usually says that
you know i mean the typical thing would
be
if you increase the price for shoes
you know of course the demand for shoes
goes down
but also the demand for socks goes down
or something like that i mean okay
so and there's a name for that in
economics which i've forgotten but this
is the idea but it's a very very
common uh model of course it's only
accurate for small changes right if i
double or triple the price i would
hardly expect
expect this thing this simple model the
simple linear model to hold
but for small changes it it's it's
actually pretty good
so it's a pretty good it's a pretty good
way to predict stuff
okay the next one
is another source of affine models is
directly from
well differential calculus in fact you
can even say that differential calculus
is nothing more
than an organized way to come up with an
affine approximation
of a function a function given by a
formula so you can
whatever do all your derivatives and
stuff okay so here
the setting is suppose we have a
function from rn to rm
and it's differentiable okay and the
first order taylor expansion of
f hat uh is called f hat of f near z
is equal to this it is equal to
now to tell you what my approximation is
i have to tell you what each of its
component is so i'm telling you what the
i component is
it's f hat i of x is equal to
f i of z that's the value of f at z plus
and then i have a whole bunch of little
terms here each tells you
about how much you've changed x from z
and then you multiply by the part
the associated partial derivative so
that's just the taylor expansion
and you've seen that before um and that
we write out
this way in fact we we've seen this in
in previous lectures it's an
interpretation of the inner product
so it says that f i hat of x is f i of z
plus the
gradient of f i at z
uh inner product with x minus z
okay which is an x minus z is
interpreted as the deviation
of x from z okay and in compact notation
people write that this way
f hat of x equals f of z plus
d f of z times x minus z
okay now df is an m by n it's called a
derivative matrix
jacobian matrix it's got other names
depending on the field right
and in some cases it's very specific
right it's about uh i mean
it's got all sorts of names like anyway
depending on the field for specific
applications
but here it's called the derivative or
the jacobian matrix and it's a very
simple
you know thing it looks like that it
says that uh roughly speaking it says
your approximation is the value at z now
these are all
m vectors it's the value at z plus an m
by n matrix
times your deviation from z on your
input
right so that's kind of the idea and
this
this thing you can think of it this way
this derivative matrix has rows
which are the transposes of the
gradients
of the entries of f or you could think
about this
that this is a matrix and to get its i j
entry you take the partial derivative of
f i with respect to x j and that's what
it is so
it's so another another way to say it is
d f of x
is the matrix um
actually this should be a z here sorry
about that
it says that it is the matrix
of partial derivatives is is is what
this this matrix is
okay um and the idea is that that is a
very good approximation of x for x near
z um
and it's an affine function so uh i mean
it's not clear it's an affine function
well i think it is we could write it
this way you could write as df
of z times x that's sort of like the ax
and then the b term looks like this i'll
put it together
it's f of z minus df
of z transpose z like that
okay so this is sort of like a and this
thing here is sort of like
b in the in in the way you write it an
affine function out
okay so this is uh this is so this is a
this is a giant
source of affine functions it's simply
you do a first order taylor series
expansion of your function and that's
going to give you an affine function
another one where it comes up is in
statistics
machine learning and prediction so
and it's called a regression model
you've already seen this before but
it's it's worth here we can actually
stack it into some vectors and i'll
explain how that works
okay so the regression model remember
looks like this it's it's
y hat equals x transpose beta or the
inner product of x and beta plus
v okay now here x is an n vector of
features
um or regressors depends you know so
these could be attributes of a patient
or anything else attributes of a person
or a customer
or of an email or something like that it
doesn't matter
um so that that's what that's what
that's what x is
uh beta is an n vector model parameters
and and v is the so-called offset
parameter
and then this produces a scalar a scalar
y-hat and that's that's our prediction
remember that a hat on top of something
is not universal but common
mathematical is certainly an applied
math it hints
that it's an approximation of something
and in this case it's an approximation
of
why why we assume is what the actual
observed value was
now suppose that we have a so-called
data set and a data set
is going to be we have a set of we have
capital n
samples uh x1 up to xn those are vectors
right
and then i have the associated responses
and those are y one through y n
okay um now uh
this is just this is just like some
observed it's a it's it's a data set
it's observed data
um now we can also for each
of the x1 through xn for each of our
data are
our observed or data sample features we
can actually calculate
um what the prediction is y hat i
is this now i mean i it's clear
a super good predicting what we really
want of course is this we want
y hat i to be
approximately equal to y
of i like that so that that's what we
want if they're close
then we'd say that that your model does
a very good job predicting why
that's that's that's the idea okay so
what we'll do is we're going to stack uh
we're going to stack
our data set uh we're going to form a
matrix and a vector out of it so
what i'll do is i'll form a vector y hat
d that d is for data and it simply
stacks the observed y's
on top of each other it's a it's a it's
a capital n vector
and i'll make a feature matrix with the
columns x1
up to xn by the way it's also very
common and
in fact honestly it's more common in
statistics uh to work with the transpose
of x but
you just have to figure that out when
you go to your internship and someone
says here's the data matrix
you have to figure out are they talking
about other columns the features
or are the rows and while in
this book we we make the columns the
features
it's probably more common on the streets
for people to
give a data matrix with the bros but
that's fine and i'll show you why that
is in a minute
um so the re what the reason is when you
write down matrix vector notation
you write this that the the vector of
predictions
is the data matrix transposed times beta
that's a vector
plus v times the vector of ones okay
so now you can see why people often work
with the data matrix being having the
rows as the features because then you
don't have this transpose here before
the matrix vector multiplication but
it's fine that's the idea
and so for example the prediction error
and it's a vector it's
is this is y d minus y hat it's what you
it's what
actually happened minus and then your
prediction of it
and that's going to be equal to this
thing and so for example if i take the
rms value
of the prediction error and it's 0.1
i could say on that data set my
regression model made predictions that
were about
you know plus or minus 0.1 i mean that
that's what it means to have an rms a
value of about 0.1
so that's the that's the regression
model we're going to see a whole lot
more about that later in the class
um so so far um we haven't told you
how do you find beta or v um we'll see
that later in the class it's a very
important
thing but for now there's no we can
certainly interpret and look at a
regression model
uh before you know how to fit one
fitting one is going to come later